où
voilà ma fierté
c'est mon pote
et
dans la chaussette
samira toi
on est dans le haut jura
april a repris dans la matinée
à ceux-là
et on va faire
c'est bon
pour le fret matin de bonne heure ok là
on n'a qu'une envie c'est de nous laver
il pose est latent et de se reposer
m
on vous écoute
aulas on va arriver sur le fort des
rousses les premiers ouvrages de
protection ou du moins ce qui ceinture
le fort très beaux points de vue du mont
fille là bas qui vient d'être réaménagé
très belle vue ça fait très bizarre en
effet plus habitués
bonjour ça vient
voilà par quoi qu'il nous reste à
traverser le lac en fête et michel va
nous proposer de le faire comment on va
traverser méchante unis alan hahn alors
eh eh bien
et l'impression de ressembler comme les
chevaux de ce matin
non
l'objectif c'est d'enchaîner baklava
multiplient vous voyez ou d'adressé donc
cela vaut mieux pourquoi c'est parfait
les filtres graphiques écoulée
les
ça fait exactement comme moi où elle est
allée tout droit
une autre mention vous avez des petits
ronds ont fait des ronds et au fur et à
mesure de faire dérober en arrive au
canada
on a vu la mise à l'otan
donc c'est là que olivier propos nous
installer mais je pense pas qu'on va y
dormir simplement comme ça il ya
peut-être des choses encore à faire ou
encore là vous allez vous contenter de
regarder quand même et après je vous
expliquerai après comme on attache un
peu au pied voilà à faire deux trois
petites attaches puis je crois qu'il ya
un gros tas de bois qui vous attend de
l'autre côté et il fait ce sera
l'interview à compans quoi nicolas
ben je vais devoir commencer comment ils
vont assembler l'engin
voilà donc j'étais comme une broche on
le passe dans un derrière ou 10 pour
l'instant c'est relativement facile
d'abord eu ce qu'on finit par annoncer
comme une broche c'est directement
rattaché à chaque poteau je suppose et à
la technique de la tâche c'est ça qui
fait que les biathlètes ont dit douter
merci en a qui veulent essayer
il passe d'ailleurs rien au monde dans
la boue et ensuite j'appuie voilà tu te
penches bien sur le court ça va
voilà c'est comme ça tu peux mettre
toute ta force vraiment qu'ils se
sentent pas toi l'aube de son oncle et
pêche sur des petites chutes
quand c'est pas quand ça vient pris ça à
ce moment là on met les bûches de
lettres taton briquet sous la main non
bah tu me cherches
disons qu'on a laissé jean faire
peut-être gens bien commander donc on va
laisser jean commandés
cherche un emplacement pour votre tarte
ouais j'avais trouvé ça on va sûrement
se met à dos pas habiter le tipi commun
qu'est ce que vous craignez les
ronflements
parfait
à la fin du canoë enfin après canoë oms
à celle des beignets il a fallu préparer
des repas
si vous voulez du comté aider à monter
le tipi et puis on était un peu plus par
le temps qu après que les jets remise
ça faisait un peu frais
cinquante entrées
la cuillère pour le trot dont on est en
randonnée et on s'adresse pas qu'aux
trimestre
m
non
le lac est encore chaud est possible que
finalement certains aillent à la
baignade tout à l'heure peut-être
peut-être se sent d europe
un verre de rosé tient des brevets à
verre de rosé
venez de troubles et l'intimité
huit personnes ont été tuées désolé nous
que je te plaisait davantage dans les
autres villes et une crème hydratante
parfumée non il avait ça c'est tout
blanc avec un soleil omniprésent géant
endormi dans de mauvaises conditions
psychologiques
je ne dirai rien non non non je ne
dirais rien ou d'autres c'est trop tard
vous saurez pas de ce match avec une
envie c'est de prendre mon sac et tout
le corps
mais ces gens ces gens est comme ça donc
voilà c'est sûr qu'à des moments on
arrive peut-être moins à supporter mais
ces gens je lui ai dit hier derrière ça
m'étonnerait pas encore eu des ampoules
dans la bouche à force de parler même si
j'ai très mal au pied mais c'est pas
grave c'est pas grave j'ai vu des
magnifiques paysages j'ai vu des
merveilleux moments dans ça vaut tout
l'or du monde
approfondir notre connaissance de la
conduite de circuits enfin où il à la
recherche des circuits ordonné on verra
au niveau du balisage nous fait pas tout
il aurait payé retraite difficulté
suivant les gens
ce fort en plein hiver et est utilisé
très régulièrement pour l'entraînement
des troupes commando il est à l'abandon
est entretenue surtout voilà on va
partir par ici en fait nicolas est un
chat
c'est ici que nos chemins vont se
séparer et pour me dit je vous propose
d'aller basse endroit la carte vous dire
au revoir à qui on va se retrouver ce
soir ce petit bout lors à la jambe
je vais produire raison alors un peu
plus de distance
oui le contenu de notre grand âge nous
avons choisi de partir à droite
je me suis dit des jeunes marchent plus
vite et ça va marcher un peu plus de
soin le soleil c'est plus sain il est
midi le soleil dessus route
pour tout le monde
derrière mark i gr 5 mai et notre étude
en [__] et m
les appels mais si vous le permettez
l'usta pour le contenir le plaisir de
venir la carte je cherche la la courbe
de niveau sur laquelle on est très léger
décalage entre nos jours l hormone y
était allé en france et du danois meego
parce que ça lui sourit fait à des
vététistes
tant que je n'aurai pas de souris
le panneau indique clairement la
direction via les signaux signalisation
est impeccable mais au fait ça pour le
plaisir de 1 de s'entraîner à ça mais
autrement on pourra y aller sans chalet
des ministres par là bas je suis pas sûr
est celui là mais parce que ta maison il
ya que 2 de route en a une pour laon
pour l'aca ce qu'on nous prendre où
sommes nous
carrefour des capucins pour moi c'est
par ici
parce que rude ab oui on regarde le
panneau alertant qu'elle mettait en
attendant chacun regarde l'expérience
le but c'est de faire son expérience son
blanc c'est blanc et rouge
c'est là donc on continue sur la route
qui la réclament tu connais je suis là
c'était juste en dessous ça doit être
les airelles alors pour faire de la
peinture c'est cette contrée chouette
toi regarde c'est pas beau ça va être un
accord on va voir le sourire des vosges
aux sources du jura ça c'était vachement
les gg pas remarqué qu'on avait tourné
ensemble à toi on est là niko t'as pas
des envies nous attendent par hasard
l'aventuré seront un chemin connu en
l'occurrence étaient légères 5
je pense qu'il est vexé parce qu'on n'a
pas suivi son opinion et que c'était lui
qui avait la carte la boussole donc et
que ben par rapport aux voies en a b i
les deux voix contre une
donc voilà je vous dis j'y suis mais
sinon bah tant pis c'est comme si une
tête de mule
c'est un homme si longtemps la grèce
antique à des cimetières la glace pour
picoler qu'elle soit leur terminal on
voit que vient bientôt arriver là alors
nico il était bien faite chemin non nous
plus rapide et où ça va respecter les
règles de sécurité c'est pas bien de
risque 3 c'est pas possible un chalet
l'espère bien il ya une plage aussi bon
lâché 10 minutes après vous savez partie
on a discuté dix minutes avec nico et
incarne la belle histoire à suivre la
route le marché rapidement moment j'ai
des myrtilles
vidéos permettaient pas de faire
peut-être cinq jours là on peut faire
plein de choses
hu
je suis vraiment désolé que ce soit
aussi beau
il ya ce qu'on appelle des jce à l'école
qui permettent d'accepter ou les
pouvoirs car il permet d'accéder aux
horizons on a attendu là-bas en bas chez
les messieurs on est partout la vallée
de la bienne
jusque là les facteurs peuvent arriver
là
dernière descente du dommage imd
consciente là il manqua sa fille ni quoi
parce que là c'est un peu casse gueule
dernier derniers mètres ces familles
pourront le faire
kodama
destiné
le bonheur est de pouvoir se baigner
dans laquelle il ya eu deux trois petits
accrochages légers mais c'est pas grave
simple puisqu'on a fait c'est quand même
a dû tous les jours pour fermer le
chemin qui était prévu on avait des
dénivelés assez assez grande
on a même été sous la pluie sous l'orage
ce brouillard on en a tous je trouve ça
plus intéressant que te prendre le bus
pour faire les jours d'excursion
c'est une belle arrivée tiens je vais
même pas et me vient et que ça des
petits bouts
oui
la gc jusqu'au bout ben ouais je m'en
doutais que j'allais pas faire plus
à 3 heures du matin au lac de la joue
non c'est la fin de l'aventuré
bah ouais c'est clair c'est un plaisir
de voir que tout le monde a terminé
l'aventuré c'est bien sa tâche quand
même aux personnes avec qui on a fait la
vente sur quoi tout le monde aura bien
celui ci vient merci à toi qui toutes
ces belles randonnées et alors tout le
monde